now you walked into the building today
and you noticed your ex-brother-in-law
yes i love him so so so there's no hard
feelings between the wow logan paul was
there but uh there's no hard feelings
between the paul's and you well i mean
jake
it's not my favorite you know we don't
we're not we don't we're we don't talk
we don't really
yeah why yeah why
i thought maybe what do you think yeah
it is i mean i but every pam pam greg
logan all of them great i love that and
it's not that jake's a bad person like
you know he did so much for me and like
i learned so [ __ ] much about what i
do and [ __ ] like that like that era of
time was so fun and so iconic it's just
i don't know
because you know as a guy i've been
married for 42 years and i'm i believe
in this thank the deal i love that for
you
yeah
but that's what i want to get you guys
back together um he's in a very happy
relationship and um i've definitely made
something but so were you for a while
i don't [ __ ] know um no yeah i mean
i got my fingers crossed for you just so
you know well i love that for you guys i
don't know i mean hopefully one day we
could be friends which hotel did your
parents deal at were they dealers at the
uh
dealers who said that in vegas none of
that now you see that see that
a good question that you told earlier
that nobody remembered or even got an
answer she's from vegas i love how i
love how you're teaching him to host
right now like as we go i love he's from
vegas yeah but my parents and i don't
think they ever did anything stable
job-wise or paid taxes or did any of
that so i don't know
now that you just alerted the irs to
your parish the only [ __ ] yeah the only
dealer in the family was me selling
drugs you know come on
but do you get concerned at all about
the uh
ramifications the repercussions yes um
like what we're looking at we just
looked at a mug shot of you yeah right
honestly i used to my lawyer now i'm a
lawyer
it's honestly bad they make me a little
too on my high horse i think i can just
like do anything and get away with it
it's so bad um no i've definitely been
sued a lot for things i've said and [ __ ]
like that and things i've done but what
do you in your book of uh history uh
what what is the most scary book yeah
what is that
what is some of the most outrageous
things in your mind that you did that
you would never do again i take out a
scroll
i take it give me a share i mean i've
made a lot of mistakes i've done a lot
of really dumb [ __ ] when i think
outrageous you're only like 23 aren't
you i know isn't it crazy how i've
managed to just rack up thousands of
mistakes um
when i think of outrageous things i've
done i don't think of just shocking or
you know for content or pr stunts i
actually just think like mistakes i've
made or scandals i've had for you know
dumb illiterate [ __ ] i've said or just
things i've done that went wrong i don't
i you know what i mean i have you killed
children
[Laughter]
just just fetuses inside me no actual
children yet have you been pregnant no i
actually never have the other day though
i was literally bleeding down my leg i
swear to god i thought i saw like a leg
in the toilet
i thought there was a baby coming out of
me there was so much blood
[Music]
you